so we're gonna bide our time wait for
our moment and then we're gonna show him
hey everybody it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead finale video actually
pretty solid episode feel like they paid
off most of the big negan arcs and I
think in general everybody agrees it was
just time to move on to something else
so we'll try to explain all the big
changes that they've already announced
behind the scenes in what's actually
going on with the show heading into
season 9 they've been talking about it
quite a bit lately if you're finding me
for the first time be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos and just careful
for spoilers from the finale if you
haven't actually seen it yet number 10
Rick talked to Sadiq about what actually
happened to Carl his backstory after the
apocalypse his mother's belief about the
souls being trapped in the walkers
I thought Ematic aliy it was a good way
to honor Karl's memory like he didn't
die doing something stupid it almost
seemed like a soft retcon like there
were a lot of big complaints with the
Karl's storyline so I think that there
were a couple of moments in the finale
that they wrote in to try and provide
some better context for those situations
so like Eugene is a really good example
of a character that they completely
recontextualized with the big twist
people are still gonna be really pissed
off the Carl died but you can see how
they used him to sort of wrap up this
giant negan all-out war storyline that
really started back at the beginning of
season 7 then paying off the moment that
Glenn died especially with that Maggie
moment even though it seems like they
also teased a lot of stuff to come is
there's a lot of big questions about
Loren cohan's presence on the show as of
me making this video right now she has
not signed a new contract so she might
not be a series regular next year but I
don't think that they would just drop
Maggie's character but number 9
everybody seems generally optimistic and
hopeful at Hilltop as they prepare but I
love how crazy Morgan gets like he
completely flips his [ __ ] almost winds
up killing Henry and even Rick is like
maybe you don't come with us but I think
a lot of this Morgan arc is predictable
you knew that he was going to fear the
walking dead so largely my enjoyment of
it was in the execution like how did
they get him there like what about the
speeches that he had during the episode
the conversations he had with Jesus they
were all great so I was actually pretty
happy with what they did with
character but there's this really
important line of dialogue that Morgan
has about how he tells Rick that they're
worse off now than they were before and
is one of the really meta things that
happened during the episode where it's
almost like the writers telling the
audience through these characters that
we understand that the show is not as
good as it used to be we need to
recalibrate and when you think about
some of the speeches from the other
characters in the episode in that
context it makes you wonder if that
speech from Gabriel at the end is Scott
Gimple speaking to the audience because
he's actually departing his showrunner
he's transitioning to more of like a
background creative role for their
larger spin-off shows like they're
thinking about spinning off more Walking
Dead
Angela Kang is gonna become the new
showrunner so you can choose to take it
as him acknowledging all the people's
complaints about the TV show of the past
couple of years especially with this
negan art I think there were a couple of
problems that they had with these past
two seasons and it largely had to do
with the way they structured the
timeline like it'll all makes sense when
we talk about Maggie because I think a
lot of this had to do with Maggie's arc
number 8 Eugene's big WTF he wants to
Massacre all the survivors by putting
them in a big firing line but it's
really you know set up for the big twist
at the end of the episode so I think his
storyline is a really good example of
like a long burn where they just go a
little too deep in on it like you really
hate the Eugene character the actor was
shamed off of social media people were
harassing him so much but it's sort of a
king joffrey situation that worked a
little too well
like they want you to hate the character
but I think they made it a little too
believable that he had turned to negan
side but I'll leave it to you to decide
whether or not it was worth it
to get to that big twist where he helps
take down all the Savior's and you
realize what he actually did number
seven of course negan Springs his trap
and you learn what Eugene had been doing
this whole time like I said they did a
little too good of a job and making the
characters seem so despicable that you
couldn't believe that he would ever do
something good rosita punching him in
the face after the fact helped a little
bit they're not totally cool but it sort
of lets you know where the eugene
character is going to be next season
like he'll be back to being normal
Eugene ready to crap his pants at a
moment's notice they kind of used their
storyline to show you the bridges that
are being built between the community
and then they sort of pay that off at
the end of the episode - they'd wrap
that up because now they're sort of
blending the Savior's and the survivors
some of the captives are staying at
hilltop some of the hilltop people have
gone to the sanctuary to help them
rebuild so which is their way of showing
you that not everybody is a complete
[ __ ] even if they don't totally agree
with each other like everybody isn't
gonna start hugging each other all the
time now but they will start working
together number six was Aaron finally
coming back with the Oceanside people I
almost forgot that they existed for a
brief period this season like oh yeah
that's a storyline they were gonna bring
them back they were a small source of
help in the comics - so a lot of this
all-out war storyline was them sort of
trying to do the comics as much as
possible but there were a couple of
characters that they cut out there was
one small group that they didn't do it
Oceanside was a part of that so it's
them sort of paying off that arc and you
learned a little bit of their backstory
- and why it is that they took so long
to come around and help out because of
what Steven augs character did to all
the men in their community negan talks
to him about massacring all the men in
that community it was an example of his
character sadism like how destructive he
was like negan is a bad person but he
still wants a form of order and it
seemed like Steven augs character which
is completely off the rails number five
was the final surrender of the Savior's
- Rick and Maggie this is pretty much
the end of hostilities with one notable
exception number four Rick versus negan
so this was sort of them paying off that
episode where Carl actually died in Rick
is sitting under the tree with those
window panes it gives you a sense for
how far ahead that they shoot episodes
because they basically shot this episode
and the fight between negan and Rick
chopped this scene out and then just
added it to that karl scene then just
added parts of it like some of the
dialogue to those previous episodes my
mercy prevails over my wrath that was
from way back at the beginning of the
season but for the most part when people
saw that Karl episode and him under the
tree people were just wondering what
that meant like what's going on with
Rick here now you know it's him just
sort of realizing Karl's dream that
things can be better but of all the
speeches in the episode I feel like
negan and Rick using Carl as a sort of
common ground was probably one of the
best ones
negan almost looks like he's getting
ready to cry when Rick
folks Karl so number three Maggie loses
her [ __ ] predictably and if you were a
little confused about why she's so
over-the-top about this because it's
been so long since Glenn died
remember the timeline she's been
pregnant this whole time that was the
reason that Glenn died because they were
caught while they were taking Maggie to
the doctor at Hilltop so if she isn't
showing her pregnancy at all it means
that it's barely been any time at all
since Glenn died which is why it's still
so fresh in her mind and why she's still
so pissed off right now it sort of
explains why she is so dark in that
final moment - we got to talk about that
- the really dark twisted version of
Maggie actually seems kind of exciting
but even though Rick seems like he's
gone all pacifist it's not that he's
stopped killing people he just says that
anybody that tries to start [ __ ] will be
put down but my number two was Daryl and
Dwight's goodbye you kind of knew where
this was going because of all the music
cues but if you're a big comic book
reader it is a bit of a change so one of
the big Easter eggs is that after the
negan arc Dwight becomes the new leader
of the sanctuary but in the episode
Daryl's like go find her man make it
right
so he's talking about Shari he tells him
never to come back and remember that
scene with Daryl at the end of the
episode and Maggie makes it sound like
Daryl is still pretty dark - so if
Dwight came right back Daryl might put
him down but obviously you know that
Morgan is going to fear the walking dead
so it's not like he's gonna go right
back number one of course were the final
two big plans that everyone has for
negan so there's Rick's plan which is
pretty straight up it's right out of the
comics they throw him in a jail cell
he's gonna sit there even in real life
Jeffrey Dean Morgan is growing out his
giant negan beard so if you want to read
ahead in the comics you can read that is
basically him rotting in a prison just
like Rick says at the end of the episode
the Maggie twist is interesting
especially if you know about Lauryn
cohan's employment situation with the TV
show so she's negotiating for future
seasons right now that's not done yet so
she could be in a lot of future episodes
or if it goes sideways in Walking Dead
doesn't want to pay her more money
because they're paying her way less than
they pay a lot of the other main actors
then she could be in very few episodes
and it seems like they were trying to
set up something really big we're gonna
rebuild in there
gonna show Rick he was wrong Jesus
doesn't seem like he's completely off
the rails because he has all those other
speeches and they seem completely
earnest but I love all of his scenes so
it'll be fun to see him sort of danced
around the crazier version of Maggie
hoping that she does come back next
season but I think part of the
recalibration of the show is in forming
more big group scenes so instead of
doing a bunch of separate episodes that
only focus on like one or two characters
and you just don't see what's going on
with everyone else the group's converge
a little bit more so you check in with
everybody more frequently like back
during season 3 in the beginning of
season 4 where you really only have like
two different storylines like you had
the prison then you had Woodbury like it
was a really good way to split the
season between those two story arcs but
there was a certain point in the last
couple of years when they just
splintered off into like a billion
different storylines that made the show
that much harder to follow well let me
know in the comments what you thought
about the finale in how you hope that
they restructure the show going forward
because it does sound like it's gonna be
very very different so talking about
more season 9 stuff there was the
Georgie teaser a lot of people are
feeling like she might have something to
do with the Commonwealth which is a
group that just debuted at the beginning
of the new world order arc at the
beginning of this year but that comes
way after the whispers arc and then
whisper war which are two completely
separate things
so I do think that they'll eventually
get to whispers I don't know if they're
gonna do it during season 9 and a lot of
that has to depend on what they're gonna
do with the negan character going
forward to like his Jeffrey Dean Morgan
gonna continue to be in most of the
episodes where is he just gonna pop up
every once in a while because he still
continues to be an important character
in The Walking Dead comics just not
quite as big as he was during this
all-out war stuff the past two seasons
so very optimistic about the future I
don't know if it's gonna bring everyone
back to the show we'll see what ratings
are like at the beginning of season 9
but I will be doing Season 9 videos like
I did for season 8 so no worries I will
still be doing Walking Dead on my
channel later this year but there's a
whole bunch of Marvel stuff happening
infinity war is releasing in theaters
next week so I'll be posting my
non-spoilery review at the beginning of
next week while you wait for everything
click here for the brand-new Deadpool
trailer and click here to learn about
some of the scenes for
the word that got banned in other
countries thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight